jennifer lopez and ben affleck making
out in public
and we are so here for it
[Music]
seems not much has changed since the
jenny from the block music video dropped
in 2002
because it's now 2021 and the couple is
back on
and still packing on the pda check out
benefer having dinner at nobu in malibu
over the weekend
the pair in all their glory enjoying a
passionate lip lock
i do love that but this wasn't
necessarily a romantic
outing ben and jen were there to
celebrate the superstar's younger sister
linda's 50th birthday
a source tells et that they had a great
time at the dinner event
surrounded by jen's family including her
13 year old twins
max and emmy whom she shares with her
ex-husband mark anthony
they're so big and so amazing and happy
as for how jen's family feels about her
rekindled romance with the goodwill
hunting actor
well they're on board a source tells et
that everyone feels really comfortable
around ben
and adds that the family likes him a lot
quote
they don't have one bad thing to say
about him they think he's funny and
sweet and it's so nice for all of them
to see jen
so happy and smitten ben definitely has
their stamp of approval
i'm thrilled i'm really happy and when
it comes to max and emmy the source
explains that since they're a little
older now
it hasn't been a huge adjustment for
them to see their mom move on with
another man
after calling off her engagement to alex
rodriguez in april
super loving and supportive during this
time
benefer's latest public outing continues
a string of recent pda moments
earlier this month the pair was spotted
cozying up to one another while having
dinner with
two others at wolfgang puck's restaurant
on the rooftop of the pendry hotel
in los angeles a source told e.t at the
time
quote they looked very happy throughout
the evening and ben had his arm around
jlo for most of the night
they arrived together and left together
the duo has also been spotted spending
time together in miami
and montana it's great they of course
previously dated and got engaged in 2002
but broke things off for good in 2004.
a source tells et that ben and jen
always knew their paths were bound to
intertwine again because of their
careers
and this time around things are working
because they're keeping it carefree
quote since they have reconnected what's
made their relationship work is not
putting pressure on it and just living
in the moment
and enjoying each other's company they
just want to be genuinely happy together
in life
[Music]